hi I'm Frank Rossi I'm a professor in
the Department of Horticulture here at
Cornell University and I get a lot of
questions from the general public and
even from golf course superintendents
and other people who really spend a fair
amount of time thinking about grass can
I have a really good lon but I really
care that I don't damage the environment
I want to be able to have a lawn that
takes me less time I don't want to be
able to have to spend the time they
spend at Yankee Stadium in center field
but I want it to look like that well the
fact is it's a lot easier than you might
think and it's a simple matter of making
sure your mo right what does that mean
keep the blade sharp make sure you're
mowing at a correct height so the grass
can grow long and grow healthy and of
course the longer the rest blades grow
the deeper the roots grow the less stuff
you have to put on leave the clippings
on don't take them away what you want to
do is return the nutrients and you
shouldn't have much problem having a
really high-quality lon and protecting
the environment at the same time